[Musique]
dans les océans chaque créature à son
rôle 3 ou prédateur
[Musique]
jusqu'à maintenant les virus n'avait
aucun prédateur connu mais pour la
première fois on vient de trouver un
être vivant qui sont nourris
en effet pour certains organismes marins
les virus représente un festin ces
mangeurs de virus s'appelle des
protistes
ce sont des organismes unicellulaires
que l'on retrouve notamment dans le
plancton
des chercheurs américains ont recueilli
différents types de protistes dans le
golfe du maine et dans la méditerranée
ils les ont disséqués un par un ils sont
analysés leur contenu
à leur grande surprise il découvre de
l'adn de virus quand un grand nombre de
ces organismes
deux types de protistes des piques aux
horaires et les coûts à nos horaires
contient même des virus dans 100% des
échantillons
selon les chercheurs ces organismes
n'auraient pas été affectés par les
virus il les aurait plutôt consommer
pour les piques aux horaires en
particulier les virus pourrait même être
une bonne source de phosphore et d'azoté
cette découverte inusitée nous révèle
qu'une et virus ne détruisent pas
seulement la vie ils peuvent aussi la
manière